and the ps4 reviews keep on coming
infamous second son is a very
anticipated game for quite a bit of
gamers I was very much looking forward
to playing this game on the next-gen
system and I gotta tell you I am
endlessly impressed with this game now
if you're unfamiliar with the infamous
games the first two featured a different
protagonist in this game it's a guy
named Elsa he's kind of a punk kid he
likes to do graffiti it's part of this
tribe a very very close-knit tribe of
people who really care about their
family and when he has an encounter with
a conduit who spreads his powers to him
he suddenly has all these smoke
abilities he can shoot fire from his
hands he can hover he can dash extremely
fast and he doesn't know what's going on
and one of the greatest things about
this game is the feel of the character
and the evolution of how he perceives
his world and how excited he gets about
what he is now experiencing because he's
like oh my gosh I'm a superhero and you
really feel that as you control this
character there's this huge evil thing
called the DUP that wants to take out
all of these people that they refer to
as bio terrorists now these are these
people who have these abilities to
harness this type of energy and unleash
it and there's a large amount of
prejudice against these people it's sort
of like x-men where a lot of people are
upset about the mutant thing and they
want to rid the world of them so the DUP
is going around trying to do that
they're enslaving people they're
torturing people and as Delson you have
to stop them
this game was incredible it's an
open-world game in which you can go
across Seattle and do basically anything
if you see a drug deal going down you
can stop it if you see a DUP armored car
going around you can take it out there
are endless amounts of things to do and
I can tell you this is a very rare game
for me it's one of the very few games
where when I beat the actual game you
know like I beat the final story there
are so many things to do that I sat
there for a couple more days doing all
of these things now that's rare for me
usually when I beat a game I don't worry
about doing all the various unlockables
but this game was so fun to play to take
control this character who is vastly
likable as a person voiced by Troy Baker
from the last of us he has Morse's in
everything nowadays but he's very good
and I wanted to continue to go around
the city and do as much as I can because
basically what you can do is you can go
around the entire city of Seattle
and 100% eliminate all DUP forces from
the city and that is so much fun to do
even after you beat the main story see
what's starting to make games so much
more of an art form than they used to be
is the fact that characters are so
important now because everything is so
lifelike with the way it looks and the
voice acting is so top-notch for really
good games like this nowadays that it's
actually starting to be extremely
important to have likeable characters
and a story that really matters it's not
just fun gameplay anymore which this
game definitely has this game feels like
a cinematic experience now also
something I really liked about this game
was that it wasn't mind-blowing ly
difficult I never had to look up a
walkthrough I never had to look at tips
or anything cuz I hate looking at
walkthroughs like to be able to be in a
game on my own and this game is a game
that is challenging but it's not too
difficult to the point where you are
punching your bed or your couch or
whatever you're sitting on one of the
coolest relationships in the game was
between Delson and his brother who's a
cop named Reggie you get to contact him
through your cell phone as you run
around the city and watching their
relationship grow and his view of
conduits or bio terrorists change
watching him experience change as his
brother dealt with these problems was
really fun but it's so great that the
gameplay seems flawless you can jump
around anything this guy's like a
parkour master flying around running
around to the speed of light it's also
much fun to play this game there's one
moment in the game where you have to
scale the Space Needle in Seattle and
when you're hanging from the top of it
and seeing the city below you and the
incredible amount of detail that went
into the graphics my mind was blown I
really recommend checking out this game
if you do have a next-gen system I'm
gonna give it a 9 out of 10 my only
issues with the game are that it does
have repetitive aspects to it where it
doesn't feel as if it's terribly
original it's just that everything
they're doing is so well made and
constructed that even though it does
feel a little repetitive from time to
time as you are doing various missions
you can't help but enjoy but as always
guys if you have played this game let me
know what you thought of it if you
played the previous two you let me know
what you thought of it I'm very happy
with next-gen so far I'm really enjoying
it let me know what you think below and
as always guys if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]